i ragazzi venuti a questo nuovo video
sono con lo stesso relazionale
allora i giudei siamo tornati sui
rockets league siamo rivolti diamante 3
nell'ultimo bisogno vediamo se riusciamo
a mancare ancora perché effettivamente
la nostra champion è difficilissima beh
questo lo sapevamo ma siamo contro den
wrong way che sarebbe strada sbagliata
giorno che più che fortunatamente non ci
sono le strade ma diciamo noi lo stesso
perché siamo più forti ha fatto
intendere partenza noi e attenti che di
via croce lo stesso che può ripartire
quindi parte anche ma allora incredibile
il tocco va bene un attimo però ha fatto
un ottimo cross ci vediamo in un
prossimo episodio che si staccata la
manopola del joystick
no no ecco è stato recuperato da terra e
si stacca un evoluto nel mio joystick
solo che a volte perdo le partite quindi
mi è successo lavoro ok non è vero
signore buono lo vedevamo andare oggi in
silver se esisti oggi insieme andato che
aspetta di tiro la palo
questo adesso ve lo assicuro fisso va
bene aspetto va benissimo traversa ma
basta prendere traverse paolo aspetta
sempre devi fare ti giuro che apriva la
porta me ne andavo e lasciavo la
racchetta andare ecco le ferme per me
bello farlo sfruttato sfruttiamo la cosa
che fermo non me ne frega niente siamo
in classificata tiro gol e gorna golf
arredo e torre la gala galaga laga del
mostro ma era fermo che è normale perché
non me ne frega niente la gente la
facilità ogni volta che sono fermo ce ne
fosse uno che non me ne frega di rai
enzo se che lo facevo lo conferma anche
classificato stavo fa male sono basta ok
se non è tornato è tornato ok sta
tentando denner abbia cioè della rabbia
nessuno sa cosa o nelle sue ruote nona
fiori a caldo ho fatto dei movimenti o
scartare ho tirato compiuti pure tu che
può avere il piatto servita si sia fatto
uno letta lo spero
41 mica abbiamo infierito no nella
seconda partita di oggi siamo contro max
games e attenzione cactus per me
possiamo dare la vittoria al esigo
fratelli lessico e la palla rimane la e
il tocco elettorali e mi pampano occhio
che vorrei parte l'assenza di salute
sorprenda mamma mia che cactus se l'è
preso proprio spinose raptus guarda lì è
rimasto fermo pro comitato cioè che col
brutto bello però fatto sei mamma
attende una vera mi dissocio mi di sordi
era per le views e che ho fatto questa
non ha scavalcato aspetta
meno male che lenta e va bene va bene
però scusatemi quanti chilometri orari
160 c'è guarda la tiroli lui tira una
teca improponibile che tratte usciva
usciva come faceva a sapere che usciva
tutto approvato gli allarmi ma porca
vacca salerno è rientrato va benissimo
ho creduto fino alla fine volete stata
la prima o poi rimane ferma da dove
buttar dentro ero convinto che gli
faccia proprio così ma no ma che era un
tocco ma ci sono anche io che lo spazio
e prova a buttarla dentro se riesco ok
va bene ogni tanto spiegare quello che
fate righe rare esatto ma perché ce n'è
andato stupisce ma perché sono stato
previdente nel riuscire a buttarlo
avanti presidente un altro e si rendano
sanders è la regola
attenzione che è partito anche lui ok
allora manda a lato per ora però se
l'aspettava no ma chi è il turno di
marco guarda il rimbalzo si no rimbalzo
veramente stranissima
per tornare ci mette un po quindi esiste
questo attacco niente traversa e gol dai
che noia che noia era allora dei nostri
gratissimo che sta la recuperiamo non
frega nulla nella vita
stiamo trincerati perché in corner
bidoni questi qua ma i fatti come
abbiamo fatto a prendere gli ultimi tre
gol cioè la cosa più insulsa le pianeta
board è che se ne sono andati quando tu
col pc a papini volta non l'ho tolta
hanno fatto 5 gol brutti questi
trincerata male questo 6 1
e allora e allora non si può segnare
così segna mai allora mi fai ti prego ok
andiamo in attacco in 5 secondi così
valuta così aspetta no
9 gianpi questa partita la devi prendere
non solo tagliarla la devi bruciare
l'intenzione di tirare di tirare puoi
tirare e vabbè questo spaventa tocca
york 11 al tiro e allora sempre poi
quelli in a porta è la porta nei più
bassa secondo me non la vediamo perché è
un effetto ottico madonna bellissimo che
sogno tra ma l'ho sempre palo sempre i
pali palo se prendevi palo e che non
basta c'era da uscire dalla porta basta
abbiamo notato che noi hanno mai quindi
sono i primi loro due tiri non
facciamoli ma tirare perché siamo
prodotto bravi a difendere ma mai a
prendere i pali così
ormai queste valli a calais tratta la
palla libera stavo correndo la palla e
si perchè l'ho buttata sui città
togliere l'ultimo secondo comunque loro
soffrono non son riusciti ancora ad
attaccare
non sono buoni secondo me quindi noi
dobbiamo farli attaccare e soprattutto
che oltre a zero se ne vanno a casa
secondo me si rendano quindi cerchiamo
di farlo e perchè da quello è rimasto
fermo marabese di vendite che peccato
tutti fermi va bene se non volete più
giocare tutto ciò che so benissimo può
ritirare benissimo è perfetta va bene
alla mamma mia
porco demonio veramente forte da 40
l'abbiamo riapparsa si pensa secondo non
stava ferma non si chiama non anche il
quarto gol
mannaggia miniera ancora più aperta però
non so rendono questo non si rendano la
stessa nota hanno suren dato che siamo
contro cei pinder l'ultima ragazzi di
oggi anche se l'abbiamo fatto tre però
mamma mia perchè allo stato gli altri
vediamo lierna va bene andiamo andiamo
andiamo
ok ok gol l'ultima possiamo anche
perdere mi sono proprio vittorie però
mamma mia perché stavo arrivando furti
per me è stato un segno del destino
questo palo vinceremo occhio prenderemo
tanti pali anche noi e 93 un'invenzione
andata benissimo andata benissimo e non
solo è lecito per paolo detto senza
neanche su rendano dc subito proprio
questo conti ma io volevo spazzarla solo
qua andata bene anche beccato
non è riuscita a toglierlo ma del suo
rimbalzo vado io sono immerso nel gioco
di parole con lo stesso angolo perfetto
allora opportuno turbante mozione per
gravi che non li punisce abbastanza però
questo gol col palo prima non avevo
pensato al ballo giusto prevista prima
palla io qui andrei via prospettato
anche juan è proprio loro da allora e lo
rubo bellissimo ok ben presente fate
sempre lira vorrei cancellare non è più
grande di un altro palo hanno arrivato
adesso
mamma mia ragazza è stata la per oggi mi
sono divertito peccato perché ci sono
stati tanti pali in questo video vediamo
di andare in rotto certi annunci tradito
rivisitata con figo però niente che vi
sia piaciuto il video ragazzi questo
momento non mi piace iscriviti al canale
anche lo stesso era ci vediamo come
sempre boys
[Musica]